hiv is a virus that affects at least
35.3 million people worldwide let's take
a look at the life cycle of hiv in human
cells
first a receptor on a cd4 cell which is
a cell involved with immune responses
binds with the co-receptor on the
surface of an hiv particle which allows
hiv to fuse with the hot cell the hiv
injects its materials rna and proteins
into the host cell
hiv is a retrovirus meaning that carries
rna and relies on reverse transcriptase
shown here which makes the single
stranded rna into a double stranded dna
which the eukaryotic cell treats its own
after reverse transcriptase axon hiv's
genetic material the double stranded dna
flows into the host cell's nucleus as
shown before to be integrated into the
genome
integrase works hiv dna into the host
cells dna hiv genes can lay dormant in a
cell for extended periods of time
without signs
at the same time as mitosis occurs in
the host cell hiv's dna is copied and
passed on to each daughter cell produced
in mitosis
the signal that sparks the transcription
and translation of hiv dna into mrna is
unknown however once the trigger occurs
the cell begins to make copies of the
hiv dna producing mrna some of this rna
acts as mrna and produces proteins
other mrna is producing new hiv
particles hiv mrna attaches to a
ribosome and uses the cells materials to
produce proteins in a long connected
strand
a cleaver protein called protease shown
here separates the long strand into
smaller functional proteins because hiv
cannot function without the cleavage of
the protein chain
many antiviral medications aim to
disable protease
once rna and proteins have been produced
in the proteins and cleaved they bundled
together under protein called called a
capsid shown before this is a nearly
complete hiv particle
during budding capsule enclosed bundles
burst out of the cell taken within
plasma membrane
they also have all the surface particles
and materials needed to infect a new
cell and reproduce again
it is important to understand the life
cycle of hiv in order to begin
developing ways to treat patients with
hiv
for more information about the life
cycle of hiv check out any of the
websites shown here